dear fellow citizens
today a year is coming to an end that has brought some
changes with it a
small change tonight right
as your federal chancellor delivered the
new year's speech to you
the smooth sometimes almost
friendly transition from the old
federal government to the new one has been well received all over
the world
it's a good sign for the strength of
our society
the year 2021 was very challenging for all of us
the corona pandemic with its
burdens and far-reaching
restrictions is in all of our
bones
and the devastating floods in
north rhine-westphalia bavaria and rhineland
palatinate won't happen anytime soon  forgotten
as bad as both were our
reaction to it also contains
a thoroughly positive message
as a society we in
germany resolutely accepted this challenge
after the flood we all
tackled together we helped
cleaned up and m  Incidentally, once the reconstruction has
started, we will still have to deal with this for a long time
and in the fight against the pandemic,
more than 60 million people in our country have now been
vaccinated.
Every day more and more
people are complaining that our
society is divided. I would like to
be very clear here  say the
opposite is true our country stands
together
what i see everywhere that is a
huge solidarity that is
overwhelming helpfulness that is
a new coming together and hooking
up today i would like to express my
thanks to everyone who works every day for our
well-being for our health and
for our safety in the  at home and
abroad in hospitals, nursing
stations, medical practices or vaccination centers in the
police stations and in the armed forces,
thank you for what you do for
our country for all of us, of
course, we
also experience different
opinions and assessments on a daily basis, especially on the
subject of co  rona this is often exhausting
but a strong community can withstand
contradictions when we
listen to each other and when we have respect for one
another
we all know the pandemic is
not over unfortunately after the past
21 months we have longed so much
for it
again the big new year's eve party has to be
today
we have to do without big fireworks in the evening
we are doing this in order not to spread the virus further
and
not to put additional strain on our hospitals
we are supporting the work of the
nurses of the
doctors who are also
on duty tonight who we work with citizens and  fellow citizens i
would also like to thank you personally
for trying to comply with the
applicable rules
it is clear that the next few days and
weeks will also be dominated by
corona the virus has
changed a new variant is
spreading rapidly you have yours  name
belongs to omikron
many are wondering what's going on  s for us
again means we can move on i
promise you that we will react quickly and
decisively and i
am very happy that we can rely on the advice
of independent experts
.
today and in the next few weeks, there will also be
clear restrictions on
private contacts  because the virus
is now even easier to transmit in the new omikron
variant
please take this restriction very
seriously for your protection for the protection of your
families for the protection of all of us
we know that those who have not
yet been vaccinated are particularly at risk of
being infected and are long and
serious  suffering from the disease
I therefore appeal once again to
you get vaccinated
I know that some people are
skeptical some are worried the vaccination could have negative consequences in the
meantime, however, almost four
billion people around the world have been
vaccinated without any major side effects and
countless  vaccinated are parents v  on
healthy babies the
benefits of the vaccination are really
great the new virus variant in particular should now be
the decisive factor in getting
vaccinated that the way out of this pandemic
my please make
an appointment with a
doctor at a
vaccination center in the next few days  you have the
opportunity to be vaccinated spontaneously and without registering
please do not postpone it until
soon
and I urgently ask all those who have already been vaccinated to have
posters quickly wanting to have the third vaccination
then you are better off in the event of an infection
with the virus
protected from a severe course
now it is all about speed we have to be
faster than the virus since mid-
november we have managed more than 30 million
vaccinations in germany, more
than in any other country
in the european union
that is good but we want to do even better
we want
another 30 million vaccinations by the end of january  n create
so that we are armed against omikron
we do everything together but also
really everything so that we
can finally defeat
corona in the new year dear fellow citizens getting corona under control that
is one big task in the new year it is the
other big task
to lay the foundation for our
country to continue making good progress the 1920s
will be a decade of
new beginnings
for this we have set ourselves ambitious
goals in less than 25 years germany should be
climate-neutral for
this we will carry out the largest restructuring of our
economy for more than 100 years
moving forward during this period we will make
ourselves independent of coal, oil
and gas and at the same time generate at least
twice as much electricity as we do today from wind,
sun and other renewable
energies a gigantic task
so that we can cope with it we are making
massive investments in new
electricity grids in charging stations for electric cars in
wind turbines decided and  much more
that creates new prosperity and good
jobs as a modern industrial country
we will achieve our climate goals
and our technologies will continue
to be among the best in the world
i am confident because we have
everything it takes well-
trained
skilled workers clever
engineers engineers active
craft businesses and companies
we will  being able to master the major changes of
our time together
if we stick together as a
community
respect recognition and good
life chances for everyone are the
prerequisites for
this proper payment is also a
question of respect that is why we are increasing
the statutory minimum wage in the
coming year in a big step
to 12 euros  and that is also important to me
everyone must be able to live properly from the fruits of
their own work even in old age
we with citizens and fellow citizens
progress for a better world
no country can achieve this goal alone  this
can only be achieved if the international
community works together
starting tomorrow germany will take over
the presidency of the group of
seven economically strong
democratic states of the g 7 for one year
we will use our presidency
to ensure that this group of states
becomes a pioneer for climate-neutral
business and a  fair world
international cooperation is
important in a world with 10
billion inhabitants
our voice will only be heard
if we perform in a choir with many
others that is
why we continue to work on the
success of the european union our
goal is a sovereign, strong
europe  europe that lives according to its
common values ​​of peace, the rule of
law and democracy
for security in europe
, transatlantic
cooperation is also indispensable with a view
to ukraine, we are facing
new challenges here today that can
not be violated  the value of the borders is a
great asset and non-
negotiable we with citizens and fellow citizens we
are at the beginning of a new decade
we are setting off into a new era a
time will be good if we actively
shape it then it makes a
difference that we decide our fate
ourselves  take it in your hand
for the new year i wish you
all the best, above all health
a big wish for 2022
let's stay together
[music]